-Hello, everyone, and welcome
back to my attic crawl space.
Of course now that we've shifted
our makeshift studio
to this location,
there's one question that has
preoccupied our audience
perhaps more than any other
and that's, "What's up...
What's up with that
tiny little door over there?"
I mean, is it where
we keep the kids' toys?
Or is it a Wonka door?
And if it's a Wonka door,
is the tiny chair --
right there --
is that for an Oompa Loompa,
waiting to roll me away
to the juicing room
after eating
an everlasting gobstopper?
Who knows?
The only thing I know
is that I'll never tell.
Anyway, you'll have
plenty of time to speculate
because we'll be doing these
"Closer Looks" here for a while.
Public health officials
are urging Americans
to continue observing
social distancing rules
even as the president
and his son-in-law
contradict those experts
and spread
dangerous misinformation.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Well, we're less than
a week into the month of April.
There's really no way
of knowing what day it is.
Every day is a week
and every week is a year
and now April just means --
I don't know -- Tuesday?
The calendar app on my phone
is just a shrug emoji
holding a glass of wine.
But if it is, in fact, April,
then that's great news,
because if you remember,
when public health officials
were first warning
about the coming outbreak
of the coronavirus,
the President reassured us all
by saying this.
-The virus.
They're working hard.
Looks like, by April,
you know, in theory,
when it gets a little warmer,
it miraculously goes away.
I hope that's true.
Now, the virus that we're
talking about having to do,
you know, a lot of people think
that goes away in April
with the heat,
as the heat comes in.
Typically,
that will go away in April.
We're in great shape, though.
-President Xi --
I know you spoke to him
recently about coronavirus.
-I did.
-Some concerns
that their economy
is really going to tank
because of this,
and that that could have
a spillover effect here.
What's your sense of
their transparency right now,
whether they're being
more accommodating in terms
of telling us what's going on,
and how it affects our economy?
-Well, I think China is very,
you know, professionally run
in the sense that they
have everything under control.
I really believe they are going
to have it
under control fairly soon.
You know, in April, supposedly,
it dies with the hotter weather.
And that's a beautiful date
to look forward to.
-First of all,
you can tell my man
spends too much time
at Mar-A-Lago
because he thinks April
is when it gets hot.
"In February, the trees begin
to bloom, and by April,
I mean, you can barely touch
your steering wheel."
But, yes, it's a beautiful day
to look forward to.
I remember when we all got
that lovely save-the-date
in the mail.
By the way, the anchor who
conducted that last interview
was since fired Fox Business
host Trish Regan
who called coronavirus
an impeachment scam.
Remember her?
Evil Connie Britton?
"Friday Night Lights"
would have been a totally
different show with her.
"Your team sucks, coach,
and so do you.
Also, it's high school football.
Who cares?
You know what I say?
'Dumb eyes,
fat hearts can lose.'
I'm outta wine."
But credit to Fox News
who will not hesitate to fire
a host who peddles
dangerous conspiracy theories
as long as they're not
Sean Insanity.
Because Hannity will probably
end his show tonight
telling people
that snorting Advil
is both a cure for coronavirus
and erectile dysfunction.
And after that they'll
give him a raise.
"Great stuff
with the Advil tonight, Sean.
Where'd it come from?"
"Would you believe
I pulled it out of my ass?"
"That ass of yours, Sean,
it is a --
it is a bottomless gold mine.
Keep up the great work."
Now, in the time Trump
was dismissing the virus
and claiming it would go away,
he was repeatedly warned
by intelligence briefings
that this was a real threat.
And in that time,
"The Washington Post"
reported his administration
was beset by 70 days
of denial,
delays, and dysfunction.
70 days.
And that's charitable, because
for Trump, you could say
it's been
70 years of dysfunction.
When he was born, the doctor
spanked him on the butt
to hear him cry, and instead,
Trump called him nasty
and served him with a lawsuit.
"There's an expression I use --
'wah.'
Some people say I invented it."
That's baby Trump.
In a normal world, a story about
a 70-day delay
in the face of a pandemic
would be cause
for impeachment or removal or,
at the very least,
embarrassment and shame.
But the President insisted that
April would be the magic date
so we could all
just look forward to that.
So let's check in
on his daily mini-MAGA
rally in the White House
briefing room on Saturday
to see how that prediction
is working out.
-This will be probably
the toughest week
between this week and next week.
And there will be
a lot of death, unfortunately.
But a lot less death
than if this wasn't done.
But there will be death.
-There will be death?
That's kind of a 180.
Everything was going to be fine,
and now you sound
like the captain
of the wrestling team
who just saw a nerd dancing
with his girlfriend.
"There will be death."
[ Grunts ]
It's a beer can.
What happened to April?
"It's become clear now
that the end date
we had been promised was,
in fact, an April Fool's joke
pulled on us by the virus.
So now we know corona to be
both highly contagious
as well
as mischievous in spirit.
A Loki, if you will."
Now, you might hear
that new tone and think,
"Oh, I guess the President,
like any decent human being,
has admitted he was wrong,
made amends by doing everything
he can to rectify
the situation, and apologized."
And if you are thinking that,
congratulations on waking up
from your 3 1/2 year coma,
but bad news -- there's this
thing called coronavirus.
Anyway, your doctor
will tell you.
Because, as usual, Trump
insisted that he was right
when he said the virus
would simply go away.
-You look at those individual
statements, they're all true.
Stay calm.
Uh, it will go away.
You know --
You know it is going away.
And it will go away.
-The President was saying
this was going to go away.
It's April.
-It is going to go away.
-But, Mr. President,
you said it was going to
go away in April.
-I didn't say a date.
-I said it's going away,
and it is going away.
-Ah, yes, very clever.
After all,
April as 24 days left,
and it's already down to,
what -- I don't know --
337,000 cases.
And you did.
You literally said
it goes away in April.
That's as close to specific
as Trump ever gets.
Usually when you ask him
a question,
he waves it away like a dad
promising his kids
a trip to Disneyland
while watching football.
"Dad, will we have
universal healthcare?"
"Yeah, it's going to be so easy,
it's going to be a blast.
Now go upstairs and oil
your hair before dinner."
And then, last week,
the media fell for his fake
somber Trump shtick
and asked him
if his thinking had changed from
when he said the virus
would go away in April.
-Is there any fairness
to the criticism
that you may have
lulled Americans
into a false sense of security
when you were saying things like
it's going to go away...
-Well, it is.
-...and that sort of thing.
-Jim, it's going away.
-But when you were saying --
-It's going to go away.
Hopefully at the end
of the month and if not,
it hopefully
will be soon after that.
-But --
-So it is going away.
-Has your thinking
on this evolved?
-It is going away.
-Has your thinking
on this evolved?
You're taking it
more seriously now?
-I think, from the beginning,
my attitude was that
we have to give this country --
I know how bad it was.
All you have to do is look
at what was going on in China.
-First of all, no,
you didn't know how bad it was.
You treated coronavirus
like a [bleep]
high school baseball coach
talking to a kid
who just got hit
by a line drive to the head.
"How many fingers
am I holding up?"
"I don't know. 50?"
"He's good to go!
Get him back in there."
Of course his thinking
hasn't evolved.
He's barely evolved.
I mean, look at him,
he looks like
one of those early tetrapods
that crawled out of the water
and learned how to walk on land,
but then he didn't learn
how to hunt or fish
so he ended up
just walking around
in circles like a dude
waiting for a crosstown bus.
"Anyone know
when the M15 is coming?
Canceled?
Why?
Because of coronavirus?
But it's April."
So Trump insists he was right
when he said it would go away
possibly
by the end of this month.
Now, you could
either believe him
or you could believe Bill Gates.
-Well, this is
a nightmare scenario
because human-to-human
transmissible
respiratory viruses
can grow exponentially.
We continue countrywide, and
we're testing the right people
to understand what's going on,
which is not the case yet,
those numbers
will start to go down.
And then, we can look at
some degree of opening back up.
Things won't go back to truly
normal until we have a vaccine
that we've gotten out
to basically the entire world.
-So there you go.
Who are you going to believe,
the pioneer
of the microcomputer revolution
who founded Microsoft
and is currently working
on ending polio and malaria?
Or the guy who once tweeted,
"Victoria's Secret reps
were nasty to Kate Upton,
and now she's doing great."
That tweet was from 2013,
and while I don't know
what it's about,
I am genuinely,
genuinely curious,
and I intend to do some Google
investigating as soon as this
[bleep] pandemic is over.
Also, why were you
commenting on that?
Is that what you used to spend
your time on
before you became president?
"Mr. Trump, we're ready to shoot
'The Apprentice.'"
"Yeah, quiet. I'm taking sides
in Upton v. Secret."
And now in part
because the president
waved away
the problem for 70 days,
we're facing both
an unimaginable tragedy
and also an economic collapse
that has already resulted
in the worst weekly jobless
claims numbers we've ever seen,
and yet Americans
are still having trouble
accessing government benefits.
Just take this story
from "The New York Times"
about one applicant
who saw jobless benefits
and was told to find
a fax machine.
Some attempts to apply
for benefits
yielded a pop-up message
that suggested using Netscape,
a browser that effectively
no longer exists.
One applicant said he was
taken aback to hear
he had to find a fax machine
to complete his claim.
My God, it's 2020,
in the richest country on Earth,
but if you need government
benefits you have to go
on an early '90s treasure hunt.
"Hey, guys, I found a clue.
If financial aid you wish to
get, find yourself a Giga Pet."
They have to use Netscape
and fax machines.
What if they want
to apply in person?
Do they have to go
to a Hollywood Video?
"Great. Okay.
Thank you for this.
Now, the last thing you need
to do before you collect
your benefits is watch
this VHS copy of 'Gremlins.'
That will be followed
by a short quiz just so,
you know, we're sure
you understand the Gremlin rules
in regards to, you know,
sunlight and water,
you know, when is
a safe time to feed them."
That's a "Gremlin" bit
that I would not have done
if we were in the studio.
But this is not
some accident of history.
There's a reason you can get
a package of alcohol wipes
from Amazon in 48 hours,
but to apply for unemployment
benefits from the government,
you have to download MS-DOS.
The reason is that
billionaires and corporations
have hollowed out
our public infrastructure
with the help
of corporate ghouls
in the political establishment.
Now companies like Amazon
are more powerful
than our decrepit
federal government.
In fact, our sadistic
President Jigsaw over here
won't even help
the millions of people
who still don't have
health insurance
get that insurance
during a pandemic.
One study found
that uninsured Americans
could be facing nearly $75,000
in medical bills
if hospitalized for coronavirus,
and yet Trump has refused to
open a special enrollment period
on the Obamacare Marketplace for
people to buy health insurance.
Now, to be clear, if you had
insurance through your job
and lost it,
you can buy insurance
on the Obamacare Marketplace.
This is for people
who are uninsured that,
if they were to get sick,
they could be ruined
financially.
And Donald Trump
knows a thing or two
about being ruined financially
because remember --
he's done it, like, six times.
He's gone bankrupt
so many times,
he's close
to getting a free sub.
And that would mean
the world to him.
And, yet, sadly, Trump
lost the part of his brain
responsible for empathy
years ago
when he tried to squeeze himself
into a golf cart
and bumped his head on the roof.
"I'm going to give you
all bonuses
because every life is precious
and everyone deserves to be --
Ow. Ohh.
Also, if you ever
need a ventilator,
go [bleep] yourself!"
So, last week, when he was asked
why he wouldn't reopen
the Obamacare Exchange,
he turned the question
over to Mike Pence
and then bragged that Pence
had found a way to talk
for five minutes
without answering the question.
-Could you tell us
what the rationale was
behind that decision and
what you have as an alternative?
-Okay, they took that up
under the task force.
And maybe, Mike, you want
to say a few words about that?
-Well, thank you,
Mr. President.
And what I can tell you
is that the President has made
a priority from the outset
of our task force's work
to make sure
every American knows
that they can have a coronavirus
and they don't have to worry
about the cost.
We're -- We're inspired by the
spirit of American businesses.
Grocery stores made a commitment
to the President a month ago
that no grocery store in America
would close down.
The food supply is strong.
We're getting food
on the table of every American.
-I think it's one of the
greatest answers I've ever heard
because Mike was able
to speak for five minutes
and not even
touch your question.
I said, that's what you call
a great professional.
-Professional liar.
"That's what you call
a great professional liar."
And it is true, man.
Pence is great at looking grave
and solemnly shaking his head
and talking in hushed tones
and acting like
he's the president in a [bleep]
low-budget miniseries
about an asteroid
headed towards Earth.
"Mr. President, what are you
gonna do to stop the asteroid?"
"I can assure you that we're
doing everything in our power
to make sure Americans can
still buy essential groceries
like Doritos and --
and Pop-Tarts."
"uh, what does that have to do
with the asteroid,
Mr. President?"
"Pop-Tarts are the
quintessential American meal.
First introduced
in the 1960s by..."
Also think about -- think about
how much of a sociopath
you have to be
to brag that
you didn't answer a question
about whether Americans can get
health care during a pandemic.
I know, I'm not a psychologist,
but if someone
gets on my subway car
wearing a newspaper hat
and carrying a soiled
teddy bear, I don't think,
"oh, cool. Another businessman
headed to Wall Street."
Trump's like a public defender
sitting next to his client
during a murder interrogation
saying,
"Notice how
he hasn't confessed yet?
I mean, and this guy --
this guy right here,
he loves to brag, a real sicko.
Hey, tell him how you secretly
write your name
in your victim's diary.
What? Be quiet? You couldn't
stop talking about it earlier.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Now it's a secret."
So, if he won't even offer
millions of Americans
basic health insurance
during a deadly pandemic,
what is Trump offering?
Well, like a true huckster,
he's selling them
an unproven medication
that's still in clinical trials,
telling people to try it
even though it could have
dangerous side effects
before it's approved
by actual medical professionals.
-And I hope they use
the hydroxychloroquine,
and they can also do it
with Z-Pak,
subject to your doctor's
approval and all of that,
but I hope they use it,
because I'll tell what.
What do you have to lose?
There's a possibility,
a possibility.
And I say it.
What do you have to lose?
I'll say it again. What do
you have to lose? Take it.
I really think they should take
it. But it's their choice.
And it's their doctor's choice
or the doctors in the hospital.
But hydroxychloroquine.
Try it. If you'd like.
-Jesus.
We've been calling Trump
a snake-oil salesman for years,
and now he's literally
standing at a podium
trying to sell us
a miracle cure.
"They call it
hydroxychloroquine!
And let me tell ya, folks,
it's a genuine
all-purpose miracle cure.
Hey, you, sir! You look like
you want to say something."
"Yes, I tried it,
and both my acne and
my coronavirus went away!"
"And you and I
have never met, sir!
So, there you have it, folks.
There you have it.
What have ya got to lose?"
By the way, you know
Trump and his buddies
own stock in hydroxychloroquine
because it's a six-syllable word
and he didn't
stumble on it once.
Of course it makes sense
that a lifelong con artist
like Trump would push
another miracle cure.
I mean, this is the same guy
who sold people
scam vitamin supplements
based on a urine test --
not made up, a real thing.
How would you
even tailor vitamins
based on
someone's urine, anyway?
By sniffing it? [ Sniffs ]
"Smells like you're...
eating too much asparagus.
Here. Try some beef pills.
They're just tiny meatballs."
Now, obviously,
it would be terrific news
if a genuine
antiviral medication
was proven successful
in clinical trials,
and we're all hoping that
happens as soon as possible.
But it is dangerous to go on TV
and tell people
to just try a medication
before that medication
is proven safe and effective.
And yet Trump is doing it anyway
because he's already
failed to supply
other lifesaving equipment
like ventilators.
At this very moment,
states are fighting each other
in a perverse bidding war
with a total lack
of federal leadership,
and the point man in charge
of the ventilator disaster
is Trump's own personal
Tom Wambsgans.
Jared Kushner, everybody's
favorite Botox 9-year-old.
You know, the real-life
Jack Skellington?
The fellow who's always
lurking in the background
of every White House photo
like a stalker
who suddenly appears
in the mirror
when you close
your medicine cabinet?
The only guy in the world
who creeps out Stephen Miller?
"Jared!
Don't frighten me
like that, Jared!
Don't creep on a creeper."
Over the last few days,
Trump has openly admitted
that New York may not have
enough ventilators to save lives
and called the federal
government just a backup...
while Kushner insisted
the national stockpile
doesn't belong to states.
-Governor Cuomo
was saying that New York
may be days away from
running out of ventilators.
Can you assure New York
that going into next week,
that they're going to have
the ventilators
that they're going to need?
-No.
They should have had more
ventilators at the time.
They should have had
more ventilators.
We happen to think that,
uh, he's well-served
with ventilators.
We're going to find out.
And we're backup.
Remember, we're a backup.
-And the notion
of the federal stockpile
was it's supposed to
be our stockpile.
It's not supposed to be states'
stockpiles that they then use.
-Oh, that makes sense.
It's like my doorman told me --
the front door
belongs to the building.
It's not for the people
in the apartment.
So if you want
to go to work so bad,
climb down the fire escape.
Seriously, it's YOUR stockpile?
Are you writing your name
on them like you're
leaving your lunch
in the office fridge?
"Guys, come on!
Who ate half my burrito?!
It had my name on it.
And who crossed out 'Kush'
and wrote 'douche'?
Guys, 'Kush' and 'douche,'
they don't even rhyme.
I know it's a near-rhyme, Janet.
I thought you were better than
near-rhymes, all right?"
They're not yours. They're ours.
The sniveling weasel thinks
everything belongs to him
because he was born into a rich
family like his father-in-law.
I'm shocked we haven't seen
something called a Kushn-ilator
pop up on Craigslist.
What we're seeing right now
is a feeble government
hollowed out by billionaires
and corporations
and run by
a lifelong scam artist
advocating federal leadership
and leaving states
and courageous health-care
workers to fend for themselves.
One lesson
we're all learning from this
is that, generally speaking,
it's better not
to be governed by sociopaths.
And the day they finally
leave office will be a...
-Beautiful day
to look forward to.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
City Harvest exists
to end hunger
in communities
throughout New York City.
They are working hard to
support New York City families
who are out of work
due to the COVID-19 pandemic.
If you're watching this
on YouTube,
please hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe.
Wash your hands. We love you.